- Wait, so how old are your kids now?
What are they up to?
- So, my kids-
- One of them
is my daughter's age.
- Yes!
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yes.
One of them is seven.
Izzy.
The other one just turned 11.
And Izzy's in a little bit
of a lying phase right now,
which I don't know if
you're going through.
- Oh.
- Just like-
- Does she say, "Oh
no, I was just faking?"
- Yes, yes!
"I was just faking!"
She says, "Oh, just kidding,"
or "just faking" and I'm like,
"No, you're clinically lying."
- Yeah.
You're a pathological liar.
- It's different, yeah,
you're sick.
This is a sickness.
(Kelly laughs)
But it'll be like, it'll be random stuff.
- Dumb stuff.
- Dumb stuff!
- Yep.
- Like, I'll like,
"You just went to the
bathroom and forgot to flush."
And she'll be like, "No."
And I'll be like, "I haven't
done anything that small
since I was four."
(Kelly laughs)
So, like, I know it's not me.
- It's you!
- Your sister's not home.
(Kelly laughing)
Like, it's not your mom.
So, like, it's you.
- Yeah.
- And she'll be like,
"I don't know what you're talking about."
- Oh my gosh.
- And then I'll like,
I'll find a way to prove it.
And she'll go, "Just kidding."
- I hate that!
She'll go, "I was just faking."
I'm like, "No, no, no, no."
It's just called "lying."
- Yes, yes, exactly.
- It's just hard sometimes I'm like,
"How do you get 'em to stop?"
I don't know, if you
find out, phone a friend.